(upbeat music)
- Hello, and welcome to
the South American segment
of the Peabody Museums,
a Fiesta Latina survey
of the national birds of
Latin-American countries.
Let's maybe begin with this big bird here.
This actually is an
immature Andean condor,
condor andino, huge bird,
the size of the California condor
with a three-meter wingspan.
And this is a baby because
it takes them eight years
to achieve their adulthood.
and the specimens we
have here are immature.
This bird amazingly was selected
as a national bird for
four different countries
in South America,
Colombia, Ecuador, Bolivia, and Chile.
And this is the bird
that to everybody symbolizes
the Andes and it majestic glider
and relies on Carrion.
So it spends most of the time searching
for that guanaco some other Llama
or they can sometimes
descend to the coast.
And in Chile are known to eat things
like beached whales or birthing seals.
And this bird can reach about 15 kilograms
in body weight.
And in this case females
are slightly smaller than males.
We have here
a very bizarre looking bird named hoatzin.
This is a national bird of Guyana where
it's called Canji Pheasant because
it looked to some early explorers
like a chicken-like bird.
But in fact, it's a bird
with a distinct lineage
of really not very clear relationships.
There is not really
anything closely related
to it surviving today.
It's a South American bird
that lives in swamps
and along rivers
and has two bizarre features.
One is that the chicks
after they leave the nest,
they can climb around
and they have three
fingers in their wings.
And later these disappear.
Okay so here we have hoatzin adult.
And in this case the three fingers
of the babies are no longer here.
They get re-absorbed
and the wing bones fuse.
And the other feature that hoatzin
is famous for
is the fact that they eat leaves
and they have a foregut with microbes
that help them digest
the plants, the leaves
and they spent a lot
of time digesting like cows.
This is kind of an equivalent
to what ruminants do.
And now let's look
at the national bird of Peru.
This is the Gallito de las Rocas
or the cock of the rock.
Here we have a male.
This is a bird
that is still pretty common in most
of the Andean countries,
not only Peru in the cloud forest.
And you can actually arrange a visit
to one of the lakes.
These are the places where they display.
You can see that this crest here
is kind of flattened on the sides.
Two layers of feathers,
folding over the bill.
It's only found in males
females are drabber brown
and the name Gallito de
las Rocas maybe refers
to the fact that they
nest in a little caves
and attach their mud
nests to a rocky wall.
So then let's look
at the bird chosen by
the country of Suriname.
This is in English, Great Kiskadee,
but in most countries the bird gets
the name onomatopoeic related to its song.
It's a type of tyrant flycatcher
and the song to the English speaker sounds
like kis-ka-dee.
But to a person in Suriname,
it's (foreign language)
or (foreign language)
if you are a Dutch inhabitant of Suriname.
They also occur in the United States
in southern most Texas
and they go all the way
to Northern Argentina.
So it's a pretty widely distributed bird
but very charismatic.
Found in cities and can easily
be seen throughout South America.
So now let's look
at the national bird of Brazil.
Sabiá-laranjeira as it's called
in Portuguese and in English
Rufous-bellied thrush, or robin,
same as the North American robin.
These are birds common
throughout sub-urban,
rural, different habitats
that are altered by humans
and it's one of the most common birds
in lower southern cone of South America
in Uruguay, Paraguay, Argentina
and parts of south-eastern Brazil.
This bird maybe looks not
the most colorful
but has a fantastic song.
And this is same with
the Costa Rican equivalent,
was chosen for the song
and for its commonness
in human-inhabited habitats.
Then this colorful bird here is
to a North American birdwatcher,
it's an oriole,
but this particular one
is called troupial
And in Venezuela where
it's a national bird,
they call it Turpial Venezolano
or (foreign language)
because it's found in
region of Guajira, among others
It's also found in the adjacent Colombia
and it's one of the
largest species of orioles.
And it's a bizarre species
and the reason for that is
that it doesn't build a typical hanging,
hammock-type nest
but it actually reserves,
takes over nests of other species.
It has to be a covered nest.
So it could be another oriole or cacique,
or even could be a stick nest
of some funarid.
Then let's look
at the bird chosen by Paraguay
as a national bird.
This is actually, here's the right species
but I only have an immature male.
So this one here, you can see
that still has a lot of,
kind of greenish, gray feathers
but already developing it's bare throat.
In English it's called
bare-throated bellbird
and this bird here I'm holding is a
white bellbird related species,
but you cannot just imagine
that this one would
look like this, pure white
and just have a brilliantly bluish,
green bare throat.
And the name in Paraguay
where it's a national bird,
it's called Guira Campana or Guira pong,
pong is a onomatopoeic.
The bird is most famous
for its loud song.
It's one of the loudest
bird vocalizations.
And it does sound a bit like a pong
or like an anvil hit with a hammer,
very loud and usually
from the forest canopy.
Then let's look
at the national bird of Uruguay.
Tero tero, or it's called Southern lapwing
in English,
it has a very thin little crest,
has a very interesting,
spurs in the wings.
You can maybe just barely see
a little orange spur.
Let me see, Oh, here we go.
And these could be used
in nest defense
when they chase away a fox
and the bird is very charismatic, loud,
attacks an intruder to his territory
especially when the chicks
or eggs are around.
So in adjacent Brazil
it's also onomatopoeically
called kero kero.
And so tero tero, kero kero
and the species now expands
and goes pretty far north
reaching Central America.
And it takes advantage actually
from human disturbance
and clearing of the forest.
Now we're switching.
Here's the last example.
And this one is a national bird
of Argentina.
This brown bird is a
called either hornero,
or Alonsito or Caserita.
And the fame for this bird
is their nest.
So here, if you can maybe zoom
in on this fortress of mud.
These nests are part of the landscape
and a pair of these in a sense
that they are found on buildings,
on telephone poles.
It's a really a common sight in Argentina,
in Brazil, Paraguay, Uruguay.
The nest is made by two
of these birds, by a pair,
and somebody calculated
to use like 3000 big fulls of mud.
And this is mud mixed
with plant material.
So it's like a dobi, very durable
and only members
of this one group of birds,
genus furnarius build
these big five-kilogram fortresses.
(upbeat music)